technically his name is Gilbert with two
L's yeah right now it doesn't even have
the googly eyes on it so I'm Stephen how
I'm a fourth-year PhD student in the
biomimicry program and I study fish
biomechanics so I'm interested in how
they move and how their body movements
relate to their total body so this is
our fish robot it's a robotic platform
that we use to answer questions about
fish locomotion that we can't with live
fish because robots do what you want
whereas the animal doesn't always do
what you ask it to and so the robot
actually provides us an interesting set
of circumstances we can change the shape
of the robot independent of the motions
that the body makes so if I'm studying
eels and tuna I can't tell the eel would
you mind swimming like a tuna for me and
vice versa where's with a robot we can
make this shaped like a tuna and say
robot please swim like an eel yeah the
robot is pretty simple it's five servo
motors connected to an Arduino and then
we use the Arduino program to run the
robot and the program that we've written
allows us to program straight swimming
but also interject turns whenever we
want and this is based on some of my
earlier research with fish and
understanding how they control their
pulses
so the tether it's like taking four wool
right so yeah there's no sensors or
anything in here deciding when it should
turn it's just a pre-programmed
algorithm and I use the tether kind of
as a leash to reset the system looks
like we have a motor not behaving
everything on this robot saved the
motors and the wires is 3d printed so
that flexible tail you see we printed in
our machine in the back and these body
shells we copied the morphology of an
actual fish so this is based on a giant
Daniel which is the larger cousin of the
zebrafish that you see in the pet shop
all the time we can make this shape like
anything our future research is going to
involve looking at how increasing body
depth changes the maneuverability so
think about plate shaped fish like a
discus or like a place or a skate tool
well places and skates are interesting
because they've turned their heads to
the side and so they look like they're
top to bottom but they do swim like a
laterally compressed fish but think more
like tangs like Dory trying to see
what's mother this is wrong just unplug
it yeah no that didn't drop the amperage
okay there's a few different
applications mainly opportunities for
underwater reconnaissance it can be
applied to I mean the Navy would be
interested in things like this but so
would
oil rig inspections as well as dams or
bridges most often the robots are using
right now are shaped like refrigerators
and have about six squirt guns pointing
off of several different directions and
so you can imagine jet yeah you've got a
very unhide row dynamic shape that's
very unstable matched with a very
complicated control scheme and so you
lose these things all the time and
they're like five million dollars apiece
so if you have a control scheme that's
more robust
still just as maneuverable you can
potentially not lose things nearly as
often so yeah yeah but the other thing
is like just underwater exploration in
general like we can scuba dive and free
divers can dive down like 500 feet but
they can only be down there for three to
40 minutes depending on the
circumstances and so because of that we
know almost nothing about what's
happening underwater ultimately it would
be good if we can spend a whole lot more
time underwater and drones like this are
going to be important for being able to
expand our capabilities in that realm so
it's a single wave we're working on more
complex implementations and finally it
can even perform something called
concertina locomotion and so once it
gets to that point it'll finish a cycle
so this is what they do inside of a
tunnel if it hit the tunnel wall it
would be detecting that